for today's classic interview we're
gonna get into the topic of climate
science climate change the environment
pollution fossil fuels and all of that
stuff and we're gonna go to my interview
with Richard Heinberg back from July of
2015 because in the midst of all this
craziness that we see in terms of
science denial from the current
administration in the midst of the Paris
climate agreement and the climate talks
in Poland which we spoke about last week
and everything that we're seeing from
the Trump administration which is
actually going in the opposite direction
when it comes to the climate there's
like a practical question that has to be
addressed when we talk about getting off
of fossil fuels which is oh is that
actually possible right now what would
be the logistics can we generate the
amount of energy that we currently use
from alternative sources yes or no and
then also on that basis do we need to be
using as much energy as we're currently
using there's there's sort of multiple
layers to this and that's exactly where
my conversation with Richard Heinberg
focused so that's this week's classic
interview think about what he told me
when I interviewed him a couple of years
ago in the context of what we currently
hear from the climate science deniers on
the right both in terms of the logistics
of getting off of fossil fuels but also
the economic prosperity that the deniers
wrongly think is inextricably linked to
fossil fuel harvesting consumption and
the effects thereof let's take a listen
I'm joined today by Richard Heinberg
who's senior fellow of the post carbon
Institute also author of 12 books most
recently after burn society beyond
fossil fuels and I found the book so
interesting because we talk sometimes
abstractly about how we have the
technology to move beyond fossil fuels
now but we're not always getting the
analysis of can we really do that what
would it actually take to fully
transition our society off of fossil
fuels and as you write it's not
necessarily the easiest thing is it
right well it's going to be an enormous
challenge first of all it is
is inevitable and it's necessary if
we're going to deal with climate change
and the fact of the declining quality of
the fossil fuels that were still able to
get out of the ground the transition to
renewable energy is necessary and
inevitable but it ain't going to be easy
the problem is that these energy sources
solar and wind provide different kinds
of energy from what we're accustomed to
using they produce electricity yes and
we use electricity for a lot of things
but only about 20% of final energy is
consumed as well as electricity we
consume all the other energy in lots of
different forms liquid fuels for
transportation coal and natural gas to
produce industrial levels of heat for
making cement and steel and and solar
panels and wind turbines for that matter
I mean the way we produce these
renewable energy technologies today is
itself almost entirely dependent upon
fossil fuels so making that transition
is going to be a challenging process and
we've only really stuck our toe in the
water up to this point I mean right now
renewable energies are mostly in the
electricity sector and even there in
most countries they're producing only a
small amount of total energy is it not a
sort of stepladder approach in the sense
that you know as a simple example we
could say oK we've got an automobile
whoo an automobile that depends on
gasoline we transition that automobile
to run on electricity instead of
gasoline but in the short term that
electricity may well be generated by
coal for example so we're just sort of
taking a step up that ladder the next
step of course would be to get that
electricity from a renewable source and
it seems that this is where you're sort
of pointing out we are we are going to
run up against the first challenge which
is that well that that next step how do
we get off of generating that
alternative energy how do we produce the
solar panels for example without still
using fossil fuels is that is that a
sore
of analogy to what you're saying right
yes and then the next step after that is
how do we build the car using renewable
energy all that steel where does the
plastic come from the tires currently
the synthetic rubber that is used to
make tires is made out of oil why don't
we run that car on in terms of road
surfaces because currently we build our
roads from asphalt there are potential
ways of solving these problems we can
produce industrial heat using
electricity which could be made from
solar panels and wind turbines but
currently doing it that way would cost
about three times as much so the glass
the steel the cement the asphalt all of
these basic industrial materials are
likely to be much more expensive in an
all renewable energy world so this sort
of ties into the other issue you've
written about which is connected to
something we've been discussing which is
that you argue that broadly speaking
this sort of status quo globalized
consumer society dependent on fossil
fuels as you've just described is not
really sustainable long term anyway talk
about that a little bit well we're we
extract all kinds of materials from the
Earth's crust and we use fossil fuels to
do that of course fossil fuels are some
of the materials that we extract but
also minerals and metals of all kinds
and you know if you think about it even
for a few seconds this is inherently an
unsustainable enterprise you know you
can't continue extracting non-renewable
resources at ever increasing rates and
do that forever at a certain point we
bump up against limits to growth and of
course there's been a very robust
discussion about limits to growth going
on since the 1970s it appears that we
are in fact hitting those limits to
growth this this century and we're doing
it at all kinds of ways in
energy terms with depleting fossil fuels
and with the problems we've just been
talking about about the with regard to
the replacements for fossil fuels with
regard to water with regard to metals
and other non renewable materials we
extract from from the earth with regard
to biodiversity really the only solution
from a long-term standpoint to all of
these problems is to reduce the scale of
the human enterprise within the overall
ecosystem and we haven't been willing to
talk about that up to this point we it's
all it's all been about growth growing
human numbers and growing per capita
human consumption well you can do that
for a while but ultimately we do live on
a finite planet and it's about time we
opened the discussion about you know how
big an enterprise can we make this the
human enterprise within the the limits
that are out there and then how do we
adapt to those limits once there with
insight and the systemic change you're
describing really would require a pretty
significant paradigm shift just in terms
of how we see our society and the role
of humans within it which is almost
weird to say right because it's humans
have created the Society and we're at a
point where we need to kind of explore
whether the current role of humans
within that society makes sense and I'm
curious what you think about the
increased automation that seems to be on
the horizon over the next 20 to 30 years
whether that might prove to be a good
catalyst for this discussion in this
particular sense often when we talk
about autonomous vehicles and the impact
that that could have on transportation
and on so many industries the reflexive
reaction is it's going to kill jobs
period and then when I say well
historically the argument that jobs will
disappear has never held back
technological progress so let's for a
second assume the progress will happen
maybe we need to be revisiting whether
this idea of work for a living period
that exists in human society is the most
logical path forward because technology
will lead to more
Meishan and i'm curious whether you
think that may serve as a good
jumping-off point to re-examine the sort
of place of humans within society right
well you know automation will certainly
occur at certain levels but we're also
talking about a situation where overall
energy supplies are likely to shrink and
that means that that we're going to have
to replace that energy with something
and in many cases I think it's going to
be human labour ironically even as we
automate a lot of the more
intellectually oriented activities using
computer technology some of the more
sort of you know basic work that we
thought had been automated a long time
ago like agricultural work may begin to
require more and more human labour and
in some ways that may not be a bad thing
we need things for people to do
obviously but also you know as we
distance ourselves from the natural
world using automation we become we
extract ourselves from the only context
that really matters which is the context
of the global ecosystem and we stop
thinking like an ecosystem and we start
thinking like automatons and that can be
a kind of deadly thing if it's carried
to its extreme so more people growing
more food locally is I think one of the
one of the features of an all renewable
society and and that's that's almost
unquestionably our future in the last
bit of time we have left I'd be curious
to hear from you if we want to be
proactive about this rather than just
react to possibly diminishing energy
resources or whatever whatever a
reactive sort of path we want to take
you mentioned the growth of local food
the cultivation of local food what other
proactive things can we do well you know
we're going to have to start rethinking
all the ways that we use energy and for
example
we've been talking about metals and
minerals well we're going to have to
recycle almost all the materials that
we're using much more thoroughly than we
currently are and of course the
electricity sector which is is fairly
obvious increasing the scope of
renewable energy within the electricity
sectors as quickly as possible
transportation is going to be one of the
more difficult sectors to transition and
so we're gonna have to start thinking
about a less mobile future what does it
mean when you know it's just not so
easily affordable to hop on an airplane
and travel from one continent to another
shipping again it's going to be a
difficult transition so localizing
basically what we're talking about is
real okeh lysing economies turning
globalization on its head and learning
how to live with a lot less
all right certainly a lot of people do
not like the sound of that living with
less is never one of the the corporate
media narratives around the future it
just doesn't seem to play too well with
all of the advertisers and all of the
the players that are influencing the
news we get doesn't your right well I
just came back from Greece spent about
15 days in Athens and other other places
in Greece and folks there are learning
to live with less and it's it's not
always easy but in many ways I think
Greece is the future of the rest of
industrial society there is sort of the
canary in the coal mine so we should be
wishing those folks well in their
transition and also learning from them
as they adapt to life with less energy
and less stuff all right the book is
after burn society beyond fossil fuels
we've been speaking with Richard
Heinberg who's a senior fellow of the
post carbon Institute thanks so much for
joining me it's been a pleasure David
thank you